j'aurais dû me présenter aux élections
finalement je pense pas que mal français
se casser la gueule aussi vite
ouais je pense que je ferais mieux là
c'est de la merde que cette politique
je vais devrait pas être leur froc ils
ont tous le même profil tous la même
gueule une basse-cour on dirait
je voulais vous dire que je trouve que
vous êtes la honte de la france
mais
tous
est ce que tu te reconnais dans cette
web de la route de la flotte de la
france c'est pas faux ah ben moi moi
j'adore ça c'est pas faut qu'on
s'attache pas fou parce que tu penses
que c'est vrai il ya du vrai et le vrai
c'est la vérité des genres sais pas
peut-être pas pour ses balades l'europe
c'est la vérité de ce que nous sommes ce
que représente parfois pour des gens
chez la vérité je pense qu'ils sont là
la honte de la france oui mais ça peut
être pris de deux façons est ce que
finalement la france les mérites ne sais
pas ça dépend de quel côté on se place
de la barrière c'est puis de certains
jours parfois peuvent être la honte de
la france et puis parfois les gens sont
des icônes comme ça un peu d'espèces de
satellites un peu fou un peu
incontrôlable avec une parole quand même
assez libre sur le film ce que vous
racontez
si on veut le quantifier qu'est ce qui
est vrai qu est ce qu il faut c en bon
en général je sais pas trop si ce que je
dis est vrai ou pas déjà à la base à la
base quoi quand je raconte un truc je
sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas si je
racontais que du truc devrait enfin même
si ce serait complètement merdes ans
qu'ils jouent leur propre rôle à
l'intérieur du film c'est cette porosité
troublante entre le le rapport que le
spectateur ou le lecteur entretien avec
eux et la façon dont ils vont être eux
mêmes à l'intérieur de situations
fictionnelle c'est comme si on avait une
version peut être modernisée de dirt
laurel et hardy sous acide ou
des compères compris de la haine des
mois pour moi gérard depardieu une
grande consolation avis accord quand je
fais un truc bon qui va pas je me fasse
on off depardieu a fait pire donc en
fait tant qu'il ya de la part dieu ça va
je peux dire des conneries tu vois une
présence rassurante quoi la libye
fictionnelle finalement les dédouane et
leur permet d'être beaucoup plus libre
que si on leur demandait un avis sur eux
sur un sujet particulier c'est qu'ils
ont toujours la possibilité de se
réfugier derrière le rôle sauf qu'il
n'ya pas drôle ce sont eux à l'intérieur
de situations fictionnel pour certaines
d'autres sont réels c'est à dire que les
actions leur sont réellement arrivé
c'est une pratique au corps de 69 fois
au moins
moi je n'aime pas trop finalement parce
que c'est vachement difficile je trouve
d'agir et de ressentir en même temps tu
dis les choses comme tu le dis non
seulement tu y crois mais tu ne joues
pas tu le vis et hume le le partage tu
essaies de me convaincre
c'est sa nature c'est essayer de
convaincre je préfère les serments tire
le plus sincèrement possible que
qu'ils me racontent des histoires parce
que c'est ça le cinéma c'est quand même
de réussir cette norme supercherie de
provoquer des émotions qui sont
réellement nous le rires les pleurs avec
du faux je dors sur le côté et peut
surtout j'ai des gros horgen qu'on se
faire une échographie d'échographie oui
parce que je voulais savoir si je
n'avais pas eu siro je me dis c'est
peut-être le x puisque j'ai remarqué que
alors il m'a dit non tu avais simplement
des gros orium d'un gros et se battent
des gros intestin est ce que vous le
voyez ce que vous le savez quand ils
sont vraiment les personnages mais à
quel moment on est vrai parce que là on
est vrai tous les deux on joue un rôle
on joue un rôle eu de la personne qui
essaie d'obtenir des informations vous
et puis moi qui réponds j'essaie de
répondre le plus justement possible le
plus sincèrement possible mais on est
quand même dans un rôle partir du moment
où je rentre dans cette pièce où je
m'asseyais sur cette chaise je joue un
rôle pas naturel mes actes et gens qui
boivent que de chercher normal